From now on,
I will use a few shortcuts here and
there to jump around the editor and
get different things done.
I'm doing this on a Mac, thus I'm
going to use the CMD key a lot, but
most shortcuts work just as well on
Windows by substituting CMD with CTRL.
Searching and
finding matters a lot to me.
Hitting CMD+T will bring
up the fuzzy file finder.
The search box forgives many
spelling mistakes or omissions so
jumping from file to
file gets lightning fast.
Most developers prefer this method over
manually searching for a previously open
tab as this involves zero mouse input
and no thinking about the tab position.
It's a perfect example of an action
that looks more complex than clicking
on a tab, but
is actually faster and simpler.
Typing an @ symbol into that box,
or directly typing CMD+R,
will bring up the symbol search menu.
This allows you to quickly locate
stuff in the current file, and
it works extremely well for
CSS or JavaScript functions.
Now I know I use this color
somewhere else in this CSS file and
I want to quickly locate it.
So I have it already selected and
on my keyboard I'm going to hit
CMD+ALT+G and
it finds the next instance of it.
Sublime Text has a very powerful
tab completion feature.
In a nutshell, tab completion allows
you to type a whole lot less.
And typing less usually results
in your finishing faster.
So if I go into my HTML file and
type in img and
hit Tab,
it expands it out to the full image tag.
Notice how not only it created an image
tag with the most important attributes
for us, it also place the cursor
in the right position for
us to enter information in.
Many editors support multiple
selection these days.
That's the ability to have multiple
selections in the same document
that aren't next to each other.
But most of the time, folks show
that off with column selection,
which can be done by holding the ALT
key and dragging your cursor around.
It sure looks cool but
the use cases for it are so
rare that I almost never use it.
So let's see how we can
do this the Sublime way.
So I have this word color right here
selected and have pressed CMD+D.
And it shows us the next
instance of that word,
without clearing
the selection of the first.
And it doesn't stop there.
CMD+CTRL+G selects all instances of
the word throughout the whole file.
You can think of it as
a global selection.
So, this makes it very easy for
us to quickly refactor.